>>> LIVE IN THE "CNN NEWSROOM."
I'M JIM ACOSTA IN WASHINGTON.
INCITER IN CHIEF IS BACK.
AT A TEXAS RALLY FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP DID NORMAN TEASE
A 2022 PRESIDENTIAL RUN,
SOUNDING HIS MOB, URGING THEM TO
PROTEST.
DON'T READ BETWEEN THE LINES,
LOOK HOW HE WAS READING THE
LINES.
NOT ORDINARY BUFFET'S NONSENSE.
APPEARED TO BE READING FROM A
TELEPROMPTER.
MADNESS AND THREATS APPEAR TO BE
PREMEDITATED.
>> IF THESE RADICAL, VICIOUS,
RACIST PROSECUTORS DO ANYTHING
WRONG OR ILLEGAL, I HOPE WE ARE
GOING TO HAVE IN THIS COUNTRY
THE BIGGEST PROTEST WE HAVE EVER
HAD IN WASHINGTON, D.C., IN NEW
YORK, IN ATLANTA AND ELSEWHERE,
BECAUSE OUR COUNTRY AND OUR
ELECTIONS ARE CORRUPT.
THEY'RE CORRUPT
.
>> YES, HE IS SAYING THE RIOT
PART OUT LOUD AGAIN.
SOUNDS LIKE MUCH OF WHAT HE WAS
UP TO ON JANUARY 6th AS HE
INSTIGATED A VIOLENCE
INSURRECTION.
>> WE FIGHT.
WE FIGHT LIKE HELL AND IF YOU
DON'T FIGHT LIKE HELL, YOU'RE
NOT GOING TO HAVE A COUNTRY
ANYMORE.
>> WE'RE GOING TO THE CAPITOL.
SO LET'S WALK DOWN PENNSYLVANIA
AVENUE.
>> WAIT.
THERE IS MORE.
LAST NIGHT TRUMP MADE IT CLEAR
PEOPLE WHO HEEDED HIS CALL TO
ACTION ON JANUARY 6th MIGHT
ACTUALLY GET AWAY WITH IT.
>> IF I RUN AND IF I WIN, WE
WILL TREAT THOSE PEOPLE FROM
JANUARY 6th FAIRLY.
WE WILL TREAT THEM FAIRLY.
AND IF IT REQUIRES PARDONS, WE
WILL GIVE THEM PARDONS, BECAUSE
THEY ARE BEING TREATED SO
UNFAIRLY.
>> YES.
HE IS READY TO ABUSE
PRESIDENTIAL PARDON POWERS ONCE
AGAIN.
THIS TIME TO LET SUPPORTERS KNOW
THEY'LL RECEIVE A GET OUT OF
JAIL FREE CARD FOR JANUARY 6th
AND PERHAPS FOR WHATEVER MAY
COME NEXT.
THAT'S NOT A CAMPAIGN PROMISE,
THOUGH.
THAT'S MORE LIKE A DICTATOR'S
DECREE.
YES.
AMERICA.
THE COUP IS STILL HAPPENING.
JOINING ME NOW, PRESIDENT PRO
TEM OF THE UNITED STATES SENATE
AND MEMBER.
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE, DEMOCRAT
PATRICK LEAHY OF VERMONT.
SENATOR LEAHY, DOES THIS SOUND
LIKE A THREAT TO YOU COMING FROM
THE FORMER PRESIDENT?
>> IT SOUNDS DEFINITELY LIKE A
THREAT.
I CANNOT BELIEVE I WOULD EVER
HEAR THIS FROM SOMEBODY RUNNING
FOR OFFICE OR IN OFFICE.
I WAS A PROSECUTOR FOR EIGHT
YEARS.
TO THINK THAT SOMEBODY WOULD RUN
FOR A HIGH OFFICE AND SAY, YOU
CAN CONDUCT ANY KIND OF CRIMINAL
CONTACT YOU WANT.
DON'T WORRY.
IF YOU'RE DOING IT TO SUPPORT
ME, I'M GIVE YOU A PARDON WHEN I
GET THERE.
YOU KNOW, AS PROSECUTOR, I'D
SAY, THIS HAS TO BE, SOMEBODY'S
MAKING THIS UP.
IT COULDN'T BE REAL.
AND YET WHEN YOU WERE THERE ON
JANUARY 6th, AS I WAS, LOOK OUT
AND I SEE THEM PUTTING A NOOSE
UP TO HANG THE VICE PRESIDENT,
IF HE DIDN'T THROW THE ELECTION
OUT.
I SEE PEOPLE STORMING THROUGH, I
COULD SMELL THE TEAR GAS, COULD
SEE THE -- I COULD SEE THE
DAMAGED WINDOWS.
BEAUTIFUL PARTS OF THE CAPITOL
HAD BEEN DAMAGE AND SEEING
PEOPLE SAY WE'RE DOING THIS
BECAUSE DONALD TRUMP TOLD US TO.
THIS IS NOT A DEMOCRACY.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT YOU'D SEE
IN A THIRD WORLD NATION WITH A
TWO-BIT DICTATOR.
>> TRYING TO MAKE COMEBACK
SOUNDS LIKE AND WE DID HEAR FROM
A COUPLE REPUBLICAN SENATORS
REACTING TO TRUMP THE REMARKS.
NOT EXACTLY FULL-THROATED
CONDEMNATION.
LET'S WATCH.
>> I THINK IT'S INAPPROPRIATE.
I DON'T WANT TO REINFORCE
DEFILING THE CAPITOL WAS OKAY.
I DON'T WANT TO DO ANYTHING THAT
WOULD MAKE THIS MORE LIKELY IN
THE FUTURE.
I WANT TO DETER WHAT PEOPLE DID
JANUARY 6th AND THOSE WHO DID IT
HOPE THEY GO TO JAIL AND GET THE
BOOK THROWN AT THEM, BECAUSE
THEY DESERVE IT.
>> I DO NOT THINK THAT THE
PRESIDENT SHOULD HAVE MADE,
PRESIDENT TRUMP SHOULD HAVE MADE
THAT PLEDGE TO DO PARDONS.
WE SHOULD LET THE JUDICIAL
PROCESS PROCEED.
>> I KNOW YOU DON'T WANT TO
NECESSARILY CRITICIZE YOUR
REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUE THERE'S IN
THE SENATE, BUT THAT WAS NOT
EXACTLY A PROFILE ENCOURAGED
MOMENT.
SENATOR, DO YOU THINK YOU'RE
GOING TO SEE ANYTHING MORE FROM
YOUR REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES WHEN
IT COMES TO DEFENDING OUR
DEMOCRACY AND CONDEMNING THIS
THUGGISH DICTATOR-LIKE BEHAVIOR
WE'RE SEEING FROM TRUMP AT THESE
RALLIES?
I THINK YOU HAVE TO HAVE PEOPLE
STAND UP AND VOTE.
WE SAW THAT AFTER WATERGATE WITH
RICHARD NIXON.
YOU'D HAVE PEOPLE RANGING BARRY
GOLDWATER TO MIKE MANSFIELD.
FROM RIGHT TO THE LEFT SAYING,
THIS IS WRONG.
I MEAN, AS I SAID.
I WAS A PROSECUTOR FOR EIGHT
YEARS.
WHEN SOMEBODY COMMITS A CRIME,
OR INCITES CRIME, THAT'S WRONG.
I DON'T CARE IF THEY'RE
REPUBLICANS OR DEMOCRATS.
WHAT THE FORMER PRESIDENT HAS
DONE, NO QUESTION HE INCITED A
RIOT LAST YEAR, AND THERE'S NO
QUESTION THEY WANT TO KEEP ON
ENCOURAGING IT.
CAN YOU IMAGINE SAYING, LOOK,
DON'T WORRY.
YOU GO OUT AND COMMIT WHATEVER
CRIMES YOU WANT, IF IT'S HELPING
ME GET ELECTED, IF I GET
ELECTED, I'M TAKE CARE OF YOU.
I'LL TAKE CARE OF YOU.
I'LL -- I'LL -- I'LL GIVE YOU A
PARDON.
NOW, THAT'S SOMETHING NOBODY,
REPUBLICAN OR DEMOCRAT, SHOULD
ACCEPT.
I MEAN, THAT IS -- THIRD WORLD
BALONEY.
>> YEAH.
ABSOLUTELY.
LET'S TALK ABOUT PRESIDENT
BIDEN'S LOONING SUPREME COURT
PICK.
I THINK A LOT OF VIEWERS, A LOT
OF AMERICANS, ARE BRACING FOR
MITCH McCONNELL TO TRY TO FIGURE
OUT A WAY TO BLOCK ANOTHER
DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENT'S NOMINEE.
WHAT ASSURANCES CAN YOU GIVE
THAT THAT WON'T HAPPEN THIS
TIME?
DO YOU THINK THAT WE WON'T SEE
THAT HAPPEN THIS TIME?
DO YOU THINK McCONNELL, YOU
KNOW, KNOWS THAT THE JIG IS UP
AND FOLKS ARE SORT OF ON TO WHAT
HE'S BEEN UP TO OVER THESE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS WITH SUPREME COURT
PICKS?
>> OF COURSE, EVERYBODY SAW THE
OUTRAGEOUS BLOCKING OF THE
CONSTITUTIONAL PROCESS IN
BLOCKING MERRICK GARLAND, AND
UNFORTUNATELY, MITCH McCONNELL
WAS ABLE TO DO IT BECAUSE HE HAD
A NUMBER OF REPUBLICANS WHO HAD
STATED EARLIER, OH, YEAH.
MERRICK WOULD ABOUT GOOD PERSON,
EASILY VOTE FOR HIM AND LOCKSTEP
IN BLOCKING, EVEN HAVING A VOTE.
IF YOU DON'T LIKE SOMEBODY, THEN
VOTE THEM UP OR VOTE THEM DOWN.
BUT WHAT WE SAW THERE DIMINISHED
THE SUPREME COURT, CERTAINLY
DAMAGED THE U.S. SENATE, AND
THE, YOU COULD SEE THE HYPOCRISY
WHEN HE RAN THROUGH A SUPREME
COURT NOMINEE WITHIN DAYS OF THE
NEXT ELECTION, WHICH PRESIDENT
BIDEN WON.
SO I KNOW -- I THINK IT WOULD BE
VERY HARD FOR HIM TO BLOCK THIS.
I THINK WHAT THE AMERICAN PUBLIC
WOULD SAY, YOU CAN'T DO THIS.
AND I WOULD HOPE THAT THE
SUPREME COURT, AND THOSE ON IT,
WOULD NOT BE IN FAVOR OF
SOMETHING LIKE THIS, BECAUSE IT
IS DIMINISHING THE SUPREME
COURT.
IT'S LOSING THE SUPREME COURT,
LOSING ITS CREDIBILITY.
IT'S DOWN THE POLLS NOW IN A WAY
I NEVER THOUGHT I'D SEE, BECAUSE
THEY SEE IT AS BEING POLITICAL.
NOT NON-PARTISAN.
I THINK ANY LEADER OF ANY PARTY,
REPUBLICAN OR DEMOCRATIC, TO TRY
TO POLITICIZE THE SUPREME COURT
IS WRONG.
I KNOW SOME OF THE NAMES THAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS LOOKING AT.
THEY'RE ALL SUPERB NOMINEES.
THEY ARE PEOPLE THAT IN NORMAL
TIME WOULD GO THROUGH VERY, VERY
EASILY.
AND BRING THE NOMINEE UP AND
HAVE A HEARING.
JUSTICE BREYER GAVE US ALL
PLENTY OF ADVANCE NOTICE.
>> RIGHT.
I WAS GOING TO ASK ABOUT THAT.
HEARING REPUBLICANS GO ON THE
ATTACK OVER PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
ANNOUNCEMENT HE WOULD NAME AN
AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMAN TO THE
SUPREME COURT.
LET'S TAKE A LISTEN TO WHAT
REPUBLICAN SENATOR ROGER WICKER
SAID.
>> THE IRONY IS THAT THE SUPREME
COURT IS AT THE VERY SAME TIME
HEARING CASES ABOUT, ABOUT THIS
SORT OF AFFIRMATIVE RACIAL
DISCRIMINATION, AND -- AND WHILE
ADDING SOMEONE WHO IS THE
BENEFICIARY OF THIS SORT OF --
>> WHAT'S YOUR SENSE HOW THE
PRESIDENT HAS HANDLED THIS?
>> I THINK HE'S HANDLED IT VERY
CORRECTLY.
I CAN TELL YOU, I LOOK AT ONE OF
MY GRANDDAUGHTERS, WHO'S AFRICAN
AMERICAN AND STRAIGHT As IN
SCHOOL AND EVERYTHING ELSE.
TO HAVE THIS BALONEY, AND ROGER
WICK SIR A FRIEND OF MINE.
BASICALLY SAYING, WELL, IF
YOU'RE A WOMAN AND IF YOU'RE A
WOMAN OF COLOR, YOU CAN ONLY BE
QUALIFIED IF YOU HAVE SOME
FIRMTIVE ACTION.
EVERY SINGLE WOMAN, WHITE OR
BLACK, IN THIS COUNTRY SHOULD
REJECT SUCH A, SUCH A FOOLISH
AND RACIST STATEMENT.
YOU PICK THE BEST PERSON
POSSIBLE.
NOBODY -- I DIDN'T REMEMBER ANY
REPUBLICAN COMING UP WHEN RONALD
REAGAN SAID I'M GOING TO PLACE
THE FIRST WOMAN ON THE SUPREME
COURT.
SANDRA DAY O'CONNOR BACKED BY
BARY GOLDWATER AND BACKED BY ME
AND I VOTED FOR HER, BECAUSE I
FELT SHE WAS THE MOST QUALIFIED
NAME THAT CAME UP.
NOBODY THOUGHT IT WAS A SPECIAL
THING, BECAUSE YOU'RE WOMAN OR
YOU'RE A WOMAN OF COLOR.
YOU KNOW, THAT -- WE -- COMMENTS
LIKE THAT MAKE US LOOK TO THE
REST OF THE WORLD AS THOUGH
WE'RE -- IS SUB-PAR COUNTRY.
>> ALL RIGHT.
SENATOR PATRICK LEAHY, YOU'VE
GIVEN US A LOT TO THINK ABOUT.
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME THIS
EVENING.
THANKS SO MUCH.
AND WE'LL GET BACK TO YOU SOON.
THANKS FOR YOUR TI